[Applause]  oh my god oh my god we don't have noses  this May from Justin roiland the  co-creator of Rick and Morty peered from  outer space you're the one who chose the  land where Ganz didn't indicate it was a  human infested crap hole without a  single redeeming value Terry comes a  series of that a family trying to fit it  in on the strange new world wait we  can't park here there's street cleaning  tomorrow man caves what stay cold Bix I  don't know some sort of human code  recreational drugs by the way I got some  heroin you guys want to do heroin  believe go back to your anus animal  rights zombie teenagers magicians  Nicole's  and the pupae look at the pupae I told  you to stop giving the pupae candy you  can't eat candy it get some sick  solar opposite  now let's get out of here before we get  arrested for all this [ __ ] all episodes  May 8th on Hulu  [Music]